many of them women and children who have
lost their lives because um of Israeli
rocket fire how do you explain that hey
guys here's a bonus clip of the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC lying as per usual Colonel I know
on October 7th there were many women and
and children um that were killed um in
Israel there are images emerging from
Gaza now the death toll seeming like
it's above 4,600 people many of them
women and children who have lost their
lives because um of Israeli rocket fire
how do you explain
that yes I I I don't want to create any
parity you know any human human
suffering is suffering whether it's ours
or theirs the only thing I can say is
that we definitely do not Target
civilians we try to strike militants uh
contrary to what these uh these subhuman
terrorists these Isis monsters that came
across our border did they specifically
targeted our women and children and
elderly and men and soldiers but
specifically the civilians you know out
of 1,300 more than 1,300 dead Israelis
more than a thousand are civilians which
is and that is by Design so we are not
targeting the civilians unfortunately
the civilians are in the battle space we
are doing our best to get them out of
Harm's Way we have called on them to
evacuate those who listen to us have a
much better chance of safety those who
don't unfortunately are at risk we will
still try to operate according to the
laws of uncom conflict and distinguish
between combatant and
non-combatant